[Aplausos]
[Música]
seamos honestos estoy seguro de que la
inmensa mayoría de vosotros ha visto
esas inverosímiles imágenes de una
detroit llena de fábricas abandonadas
calles desoladas y barrios con un montón
de casas tapiadas abandonadas o
directamente de ruedas la ciudad más
poblada del estado de michigan se
convirtió un buen día en la capital
americana del sector del automóvil y por
consiguiente también en la capital
mundial del coche empresas tan
importantes como la ford o la tienen al
motor tenían sus centros de producción
justo aquí de esta forma en 1950 esta
ciudad llegó a tener casi 2 millones de
habitantes en ese momento detroit se
había convertido en uno de los lugares
más atractivos para miles y miles de
trabajadores de todo el país que ansiaba
no alcanzar lo que se conoce como el
sueño americano hablamos ni más ni menos
que de la cuarta mayor ciudad de los
eeuu tan sólo por detrás de nueva york
los ángeles y chicago sin embargo algo
pasó y desde precisamente esa década de
los 50 todo empezó a derrumbarse como si
fuese un castillo de naipes
[Música]
muchísimas empresas empezaron a cerrar
hubo recortes en las cadenas de
producción y muchas fábricas de empresas
satélites del sector del automóvil se
vieron afectadas todo empezó a venirse
abajo y fijaos si era grave la tormenta
que acababa de ponerse en marcha que
para 1963 ya había perdido casi 200.000
habitantes sí sí 200 mil habitantes en
tan solo 10 años y lo que es aún peor
desde entonces esta tónica se ha
mantenido década tras década hasta hoy y
es que en este preciso momento la
población de la ciudad apenas supera los
670 mil habitantes
[Música]
como podéis ver en el gráfico los datos
no dan tregua casi parece la
representación de una ciudad condenada a
convertirse en una especie de localidad
fantasma desde que estalló la crisis la
que llego a ser una de las ciudades más
pujantes de los eeuu ha perdido más del
60% de sus habitantes
[Música]
además la inmensa mayoría de los que se
quedaron fueron personas de renta muy
baja a personas que no pocos casos mal
viven en un entorno prácticamente
marginal tremendamente pobre y muy
inseguro
el caso amigos y amigas es que sobre
este fenómeno podemos encontrar dos
grandes líneas argumentales enfrentadas
los que le echan la culpa al capitalismo
y los que le echan la culpa a justo todo
lo contrario a políticas terriblemente
malas que condujeron a ésta
fantasmagórica situación pero lo cierto
es que de alguna u otra forma para la
mayoría de la gente dentro y se ha
convertido en algo así como una especie
de icono viviente del fracaso del
capitalismo norteamericano o al menos de
un ejemplo de que ese sueño americano
del que tanto nos hablan no siempre
funciona ahora bien es esto realmente
así de verdad fue la caída de detroit
culpa del malvado capitalismo como es
hoy y qué futuro le espera a esta ciudad
pues a estas ya otras preguntas son las
que vamos a tratar de contestar hoy aquí
en visual político atentos
[Música]
el rugir del motor
fijaos en estas imágenes
[Música]
cada uno de estos espacios vacíos que
veis en las distintas manzanas un día
estuvieron llenos de casas pero entonces
por qué hay tantos huecos vacíos pues
porque durante los últimos años el
ayuntamiento de detroit se ha esforzado
un montón en derribar cada casa
abandonada para que ésta no fuera
ocupada o utilizada para actividades
ilegales o para el consumo de sustancias
prohibidas es decir para evitar en la
medida de lo posible que aparecieran
nuevos focos de criminalidad
descontrolada
sin embargo un día todos estos barrios y
marginales fueron zonas normales de
clase media y trabajadora norteamericana
como las que podríamos encontrar en
cualquier otra ciudad estadounidense
pero hoy y desde hace ya muchos años son
sitios donde la verdad es casi mejor que
no se te ocurra meterte porque de
hacerlo si sales bueno y salir de ella
salgo y con todas tus pertenencias
digamos que casi que podrías considerar
te todo un afortunado el caso es que
estos barrios fueron el resultado de un
enorme boom demográfico en cosa de
apenas tres décadas en apenas 30 años
entre 1920 y 1950 la población de
metroid se multiplicó por 2 tan sólo en
los 10 años que van desde 1920 hasta
1930 la población creció en casi 600.000
personas y la pregunta es por qué empezó
a llegar tanta gente a detroit de
repente que ofrecía la ciudad de dónde
venían
[Música]
desde finales del siglo 19 y principios
del 2030 empezó a desarrollar una
potente industria del automóvil decenas
de pequeñas fábricas de antiguos y
rudimentarios coches empezaron a abrirse
en distintas partes de la ciudad y una
de ellas fue precisamente la de henry
ford quien fundó allí en 1899 la detroit
automobile company el negocio no fue
todo lo bien que se esperaba y apenas
dos años después cerró habiendo vendido
tan sólo 20 coches y perdido el
equivalente a más de 2 millones y medio
de dólares de hoy y tras un segundo
intento fallido a la tercera en 1903
fort fundó la ford motor company con una
inversión de menos de 800 mil dólares de
hoy en día y amigos como dice el dicho
la tercera fue la vencida
[Música]
pese a lo que nos han contado siempre de
henri ford no fue el primero en producir
coches en serie no el primer coche
producido en serie fue de hecho uno de
los móviles el curso más
[Aplausos]
pero sin embargo lo que sí es cierto es
que fue ford quien consiguió llevar este
sistema a unos niveles de eficiencia y
rentabilidad nunca antes vistos de tal
forma que logró reducir un montón tanto
los costes como los tiempos de
producción
[Música]
de hecho el fordismo que es como se
conoce a este sistema de producción fue
lo que cambió para siempre detroit y ojo
porque no me estoy refiriendo sólo a la
economía de la ciudad oa su modelo
industrial sino también a su estructura
demográfica y es que el modelo de fort
empezó a ser replicado y las fábricas
empezaron a crecer y crecer y claro eso
significaba que cada vez se necesitaban
más y más trabajadores lo que causó un
boom de nuevos habitantes que en su
mayoría eran miembros de las comunidades
negras del sur y eso bueno digamos que
no fue algo tan sencillo pensad que
estamos hablando de principios del siglo
20 en ese momento eeuu como
prácticamente como los países
occidentales eran tremendamente racistas
y claro en ese contexto la llegada de
miles de personas negras a una ciudad
que hasta entonces fue mayoritariamente
blanca generó todo tipo de problemas
muchas tensiones raciales y una enorme
desconfianza entre los habitantes de
toda la vida y esto es lo que explica
que los blancos empezaron a marchar a la
periferia a zonas residenciales de nueva
construcción de tal forma que las zonas
más céntricas de detroit se fueron
convirtiendo con los años en las zonas
más humildes y marginales por culpa de
la exclusión social y una acuciante
falta de suficientes viviendas para
albergar a todo
trabajadores que estaban llegando pero
puede que ahora muchos estéis pensando
pero vamos a ver enrique y diablos tiene
que ver las tensiones raciales y todos
estos problemas con la debacle de
metroid pues amigos mucho más de lo que
podríamos llegar a pensar y es que
veréis todas estas tensiones raciales se
fueron alimentando y creciendo con el
paso de los años y en ciertas ocasiones
terminaban explotando llegando en
algunos casos incluso a provocar
disturbios muy graves disturbios como el
de 1967 en el que por un falso rumor se
saquearon más de 2500 tiendas
pertenecientes a la población blanca y
donde más de 400 edificios incluidos
muchos edificios residenciales de
viviendas fueron calcinados quemados y
aquí aquí llegamos a un momento crucial
cuál pensáis que fue la respuesta de las
autoridades pues atentos porque para
muchos expertos aquí está precisamente
el origen real de un problema que ha
continuado hasta el día de hoy
los políticos de detroit y de michigan
no querían bajo ningún concepto que algo
similar a los disturbios de 1967
volviese a pasar así que emprendieron
ambiciosos programas sociales como la
contratación de minorías negras en el
sector público el reparto de subsidios
por la puesta en marcha de la ley de
equidad de vivienda de michigan un
ambicioso programa de vivienda asequible
que buscaba fijar población en el centro
de detroit un espacio urbano vaciado por
la marcha de población blanca a los
extrarradios y a otras ciudades de tren
y se convirtió así en un gran
laboratorio de pruebas pero este
experimento social fracasó con el paso
de los años y este tipo de políticas
hicieron que buena parte de los
habitantes de detroit se convirtieran en
rentistas de las administraciones
públicas lo que con el paso de los años
generó una nueva brecha social buena
parte de la población no estaba
integrada en el sector productivo y no
tenían alicientes incentivos para
competir y lo que es aún peor este tipo
de políticas no funcionaron a la hora de
corregir los grandes problemas por los
que atravesaba la ciudad no consiguieron
acabar con la exclusión social ni
tampoco con las tensiones raciales no se
frenó la huida de empresas y vecinos no
se logró atajar la violencia y no se
estimuló la creación de
las empresas poco a poco de todo y se
fue apagando sorprendidos pues espera
hace un momento porque esto no ha hecho
más que comenzar
[Aplausos]
y es que para colmo las viejas fábricas
de automóviles de principios del siglo
20 empezaron a tener que cerrar ya no
eran operativas para la enorme
producción que requerían los nuevos
tiempos ni tampoco para la creciente
automatización que empezaba a utilizarse
en este tipo de plantas así que las
grandes marcas del automóvil pues
comenzaron a construir nuevas factorías
primero en la periferia en las afueras
de detroit y más tarde ante la creciente
conflictividad de la ciudad la huida de
muchos especialistas y los mayores
costes fiscales y laborales como
consecuencia de todos esos planes
sociales pues a otros lugares de los
eeuu lo que por supuesto pues aceleró el
proceso de despoblación y
empobrecimiento de la ciudad y así de
esta forma mientras la constante pérdida
de empresas y de vecinos que terminaban
por decidir hacer las maletas y poner
tierra de por medio no se reducía poco a
poco detroit fue convirtiéndose en una
ciudad cada vez más dependiente de los
programas sociales y eso eso hizo a su
vez que la situación financiera se
convirtiera en toda una bomba de
relojería
y es que veréis por un lado la pérdida
de población y de tejido productivo hizo
claro que los ingresos fiscales se
hundiera pero por otro lado los
diferentes alcaldes dentro y seguían
gastando y gastando dinero a manos
llenas para tratar de revertir el
problema desde enormes planes sociales
hasta grandes programas de obra pública
y claro si por un lado tenemos menos
ingresos y por otro gastamos más
entonces el desastre está servido y
sabéis que eso es exactamente lo que
ocurrió las finanzas de la ciudad fueron
estando cada vez peor hasta que
finalmente en el año 2013 la ciudad se
enfrentó al default simple y llanamente
detroit quebró pero el momento amigos
porque aquí justo aquí es donde comienza
una historia completamente diferente
queréis saber cómo es el detroit de hoy
y cómo puede ser el de troy de mañana
pues atentos un nuevo comienzo para
detroit es posible imaginados por un
momento la situación tratar de haceros
una recreación mental antes del default
de 2013 de héctor y que estaba tan
arruinada que no tenía dinero ni
siquiera para mantener los servicios
públicos básicos a un nivel
ni basuras ni aguas ni el mantenimiento
de las tuberías ni alcantarillado ni qué
decir pues tampoco la seguridad y es que
con el paso de los años la ciudad
acumuló una enorme deuda de 14.000
millones de dólares y tan solo el 2013
el déficit presupuestario fue de 327
millones y ojo que hablamos de una
ciudad que por aquel entonces apenas
tenía 690 mil habitantes es decir la
deuda municipal era de más de 20 mil
dólares por cada habitante y eso amigos
es mucho pero que muchísimo dinero para
un pequeño ayuntamiento de hecho es casi
tanto como toda la deuda pública per
cápita de un país nada saneado como por
ejemplo españa teniendo en cuenta a
ayuntamientos regiones gobierno central
etcétera etcétera y por supuesto un
ayuntamiento pues no tienen los recursos
las fuentes de ingresos que tiene un
país entero pues bien el caso es que
esta situación provocó que para tratar
de salir del hoyo en la ciudad me diese
la tijera por ejemplo los empleados
públicos tuvieron que aceptar
importantes recortes salariales y
excelencias forzosa sin sueldo y el
propio gobierno federal de los eeuu tuvo
que intervenir las cuentas para
reestructurar las la buena noticia para
detroit es que todo este proceso digamos
que no duró mucho tras la intervención
del gobierno
y los acuerdos para eliminar y
reestructurar más de 7 mil millones de
deuda la ciudad logró salir de la
bancarrota por cierto apunte esto
significa básicamente que muchos
acreedores perdieron una buena parte de
su dinero y ojo que hablamos por ejemplo
de los fondos de pensiones
[Música]
eso sí desde entonces la ciudad ha
tenido que seguir un estricto plan de
control del gasto que ha obligado a las
autoridades a presentar cuentas con
superávit año tras año
algo que ha permitido seguir reduciendo
la deuda e ir poco a poco mejorando las
condiciones de seguridad y los servicios
públicos por ejemplo las parcelas vacías
que veíamos al principio de este vídeo
que estaban ocupadas por casas en ruinas
que en muchos casos funcionaban como
focos de delincuencia el ayuntamiento ni
siquiera tenía dinero para demoler las
sin embargo todo esto fue cambiando poco
a poco desde el default
de hecho contra todo pronóstico de tuit
se ha convertido en un pequeño centro de
inversiones las inversiones privadas
llevan años regresando a la ciudad la
gente un día tenía miedo de invertir en
la ciudad simplemente descartaron
hacerlo en detroit si vas a detroit
ahora es una ciudad diferente a la que
era hace cinco años en una imagen
diferente y es una ciudad vibrante james
mack tibia miembro gerente de mac tibia
associates en detroit muchas de estas
inversiones están llegando sobre todo de
grandes capitales de nueva york y los
ángeles y a día de hoy es posible ver
proyectos de rehabilitación de edificios
gigantescos que estaban abandonados en
pleno centro de la ciudad
[Música]
y no sólo eso sino que incluso la propia
industria está empezando a florecer de
nuevo fiat chrysler planea una inversión
en michigan con 6 mil 500 empleos la
automovilística italoamericana dijo que
planea gastar 4500 millones de dólares
durante los próximos tres años en
actualizar varias fábricas en detroit y
remodelar una planta de motores para
fabricar jeeps un esfuerzo que según la
compañía crearía alrededor de 6 mil 500
nuevos empleos y aún más en 2018 la ford
motor company compró la antigua estación
central de michigan una gran mole
abandonada que siempre siempre salen las
imágenes de detroit y empezó a
rehabilitarla con una inversión de 740
millones de dólares la idea de fort es
mover a este edificio sus equipos de
desarrollo de vehículos autónomos
dándoles poco a poco de esta forma una
segunda oportunidad a la ciudad que les
vio crecer además del punto de vista
social uno de los programas que más
esperanzas está generando es
curiosamente un ambicioso plan de
reinserción que las autoridades han
puesto en marcha para todas aquellas
personas que se han enfrentado a la
cárcel y amigos quererme que hablamos de
muchas pero que mucha gente pensaba que
esta ciudad ha sido durante décadas
presa del crimen y que todavía a día de
hoy sigue siendo uno de los lugares más
peligrosos de los eeuu para que os
hagáis una idea aproximadamente el 15
por ciento de toda la población tiene
antecedentes
delitos graves
[Música]
el departamento de correccionales de
michigan libera alrededor de 9000 presos
cada año de los cuales el 25% terminan
yendo al condado de wayne en detroit
salir de la cárcel y reinsertar de la
sociedad es difícil en todos los países
pero en eeuu puede llegar a serlo aún
más aproximadamente el 60% de las
personas que salen en libertad
condicional en michigan no tienen un
empleo y muchos se ven tentados a volver
a delinquir para poder subsistir además
otro problema al que se enfrenta es que
muchos no consiguen encontrar a un
casero que les alquile una vivienda por
ello el ayuntamiento de detroit ha
aprobado una ordenanza que evita que la
gran mayoría de los propietarios pueda
descartar alquilarle una vivienda a una
persona en base a sus antecedentes
penales asimismo también se ha puesto en
marcha planes para favorecer la
participación laboral de los antiguos
reclusos y se han creado asociaciones
que tienen como objetivo acompañar a
estas personas para que logren una
reinserción plena
por cierto pensándolo ahora creo que mi
ser político tenemos pendiente hablar de
esta cuestión a fondo el caso es que sin
embargo amigos a pesar de todos los
logros que se han visto los últimos años
en detroit la crisis de la pandemia en
el coronavirus se está poniendo todos
esos avances otra vez en peligro a
medida que el coronavirus hace mella en
detroit la pandemia magnifica la pobreza
y las disparidades raciales en efecto la
grave crisis económica que se avecina
por culpa de esta pandemia está poniendo
en riesgo muchas de las inversiones que
se habían conseguido traer a detroit ya
que invertir en este lugar conlleva
bastantes más riesgos que en otras
partes de los eeuu y además es que el
coronavirus ha golpeado muy fuerte a
detroit y por si fuese poco la población
más afectada por la pandemia está siendo
precisamente la más vulnerable es decir
la población negra en fin amigos esta es
la historia del milagro la debacle y el
aparente renacer de una de las ciudades
más importantes del despegue industrial
del siglo 20 y todo un símbolo del poder
económico de los eeuu una ciudad que nos
cuenta como en muchas ocasiones la
intención de las políticas públicas no
coincide con sus resultados pero ahora
ahora turno para ti crees que detroit
podría convertirse en la nueva capital
del motor de eeuu en un par de décadas
podrá la ciudad sortear la crisis de el
coronavirus y seguir creciendo una vez
pase lo peor de la pandemia qué opinas
acerca de cómo las tensiones raciales y
las malas políticas públicas acabaron
con una de las ciudades más vibrantes de
los eeuu como siempre y déjanos tu
respuesta aquí abajo en los comentarios
que nos encantará a leerlas y ya sabéis
si este vídeo se resulta interesante no
olvidéis darle a like suscribiros abisal
politics si eres que aún no lo habéis
hecho y darle a la campanita para estar
al tanto de todas nuestras
actualizaciones una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]